Carrusel de las artes
María Carolina piña
[Música]
un honor saludarles desde el balneario
de cannes para este número especial de
Carrusel de las artes desde el festival
de cine más importante del mundo Así que
Pónganse cómodos porque ya mismo les
hacemos un repaso de lo que acontece en
esta fiesta del cine
[Música]
el festival de Canes abrió por todo lo
alto rindiendo un cálido homenaje al
actor Michael Douglas quien recibió una
palma de oro de honor por el conjunto de
su carrera can extiende un puente con
Hollywood invitando a superestrellas del
Séptimo arte Johnny Depp con peluca
tacones y tronos se robó las miradas en
la inauguración del festival de Canes
durante la proyección de la película
John el dos veces ganador de la palma de
oro Rubén oslon preside en 2023 el
Jurado encargado de examinar los
veintiún largometrajes que compiten por
la máxima recompensa del festival de
cannes iremos también al mercado del
cine que tiene lugar durante el festival
evento gigantesco que este año tiene a
España como invitada de honor
[Música]
festival de carne
cine de autor glamur estrellas y un
público que se agolpa todos los días en
el Palacio de los festivales para ver a
sus artistas favoritos Ese es el
ambiente que reina en el festival de
cine de Canes una fiesta del Séptimo
arte mundial que reúne todos los años al
selecto mundo del cine en este balneario
de la Riviera francesa y en la edición
número 76 el festival de cannes rindió
homenaje a Michael Douglas un actor
popular quien se ha notado también
algunos triunfos como productor
la espera valió la pena el
estadounidense Michael Douglas recibió a
los 78 años su primer reconocimiento en
cannes en la ceremonia de apertura del
festival la actriz suma Le entregó la
palma de oro de honor por el conjunto de
su carrera su primer Oscar lo obtuvo sin
embargo como productor de la cinta
emblemática alguien voló sobre el nido
del cuco protagonizada por Jack
nicholson
los roles de seductor atormentado lo
volvieron famoso con basic Einstein y
Atracción fatal Douglas llevó la química
a la pantalla grande junto a
superestrellas como Sharon Stone y glenn
Cloud
al darle vida a Gordon gecko el corredor
de bolsa más famoso y despiadado del
mundo Michael Douglas obtuvo el Oscar
como mejor actor y el globo de oro a la
mejor película en 1988
un estilo y una elegancia que lo
acompañan en todos sus papeles incluso
bajo el acecho de un anónimo perverso en
The Game
[Música]
pero fue frente a las cámaras de Steven
soderberg que el veterano Douglas brilló
en sus últimos trabajos primero en la
película tráfico y luego con la cinta
behind de candelabra estrenada en cannes
en la que protagoniza al pianista
homosexual liberaleche
con más de 70 años Michael Douglas
siguió ganando premios protagonizando la
serie de komisky metal su papel como
profesor de actuación amargado le dio un
globo de oro como mejor actor de comedia
en cannes el público le reservó una
larga y calurosa ovación
y otro que desfilo por la alfombra roja
fue el actor estadounidense Johnny Depp
protagonista de la película
el festival de cannes comenzó con esta
película francesa de época la historia
apasionada y adúltera entre el rey Luis
15 y esta mujer cuyos encantos le
permitieron convertirse en la favorita
de la corte más importante del mundo el
Palacio de Versalles tres dos uno
[Música]
Versalles amor y escándalo Esos son los
ingredientes de la película que inauguró
el festival de cannes de ibagué es el
retrato de una de las mujeres más
influyentes y detestadas de la monarquía
francesa La Irresistible amante de Luis
15 quien sacó provecho de sus encantos
para ascender socialmente hasta poner al
rey de Francia a sus pies esta cinta fue
escrita dirigida y protagonizada por la
francesa mayween quien confesó su
fascinación
quería rehabilitar este personaje
defenderlo desde que supe de ella me
sedujo completamente es fascinante y a
la vez tenía una personalidad compleja Y
contradictoria era seductora y venal
despertó admiración y rechazo en la
corte soy muy diferente de ella y sin
embargo quería tomar su defensa
de fondo
en el papel de Luis quince la estrella
de Hollywood Johnny Depp quien después
de protagonizar uno de los juicios más
mediáticos de los últimos tiempos contra
su ex esposa regresó al cine por la
puerta grande los zapatos de un monarca
a pesar de que su lengua no es el
francés
admiro mucho a Johnny Depp quería que él
diera vida a Luis 15 más allá de su
nacionalidad Johnny podía interpretarlo
Se comprometió completamente con el
proyecto no podía descartar a un actor
como él por el simple hecho de no ser
francés Johnny tiene una historia
personal con este país ha echado raíces
en Francia
es una película de pompa juegos de poder
y rivalidades filmada en el mismísimo
Palacio de Versalles una de las cintas
más esperadas del festival de cannes
aunque proyectada fuera de la
competencia
y ahora los invitamos a descubrir al
presidente de la Competencia por la
palma de oro el director sueco Rubén
oslon es un maestro del humor negro y de
la sátira un avisé un invitado frecuente
del festival de Canes
[Música]
el ser humano en su estado más primitivo
vanidoso y vergonzoso esa es la materia
con la que el irreverente Rubén ostrum
fabrica sus personajes sus cintas son
espejos de la sociedad Y eso lo ha
llevado en la última década a triunfar
en cannes en tres ocasiones
[Música]
la primera en 2014 cuando presentó su
cinta fuerza mayor en la sección una
cierta mirada la historia de unas
vacaciones familiares en una Selecta
estación de esquí que se vuelven
incómodas Cuando el padre deja a su
mujer e hijos para salvar su pellejo
ante una avalancha
fuerza mayor se llevó el premio del
Jurado tres años después Rubén Luna alzó
su primera palma de oro gracias a dos
cuerre un retrato feroz del mundo del
arte contemporáneo a la vez artificial y
crudo
[Música]
en su último largometraje sin
filtros sueco ataca sin Piedad lo
obsceno y absurdo de la élite
privilegiada reunida en el naufragio de
un yate invaluable
sin filtro se alzó en 2022 con la palma
de oro y este año el sarcástico oslum
preside el Jurado de la competencia
junto a personalidades como Damián sifón
Doña minuche y suya yukuno
quiero que nos alejemos del consenso en
el Jurado el estar en grupo y hablar
influye mucho en la manera como sentimos
una película para romper el consenso
quiero que cada miembro de su voz en las
deliberaciones les pido que luchen por
su opinión y su visión del mundo en eso
consiste el cine
sin miedo a chocar y lleno de humor
negro Rubén oslon Toma las riendas de
cannes 2023
ponemos ahora el foco en otro mega
evento aquí en cannes durante el
festival se trata del mercado del cine
donde tiene lugar cientos de
presentaciones y encuentros y este año
el país invitado de honor es España
vamos a descubrirlo
la feria cinematográfica más grande del
mundo se despliega cada año en la
cuasete de cannes El Mercado del cine
reúne a 13.000 profesionales para
presentar 4.000 películas en una
treintena de salas un mega mercado donde
se vende y se compra el cine del Mañana
es el director del mercado del cine el
licenciado
hay proyecciones confidenciales para los
compradores los que adquieren las cintas
para los difusores o para plataformas de
streaming ellos ven una película o un
trozo de película y se posicionan hacen
ofertas es también un momento para
valorizar nuevos talentos emergentes
para todos los que buscan el perfil que
logrará el éxito de futuros proyectos
financiados
algún día
120 países se dan cita en este mercado
este año España gigante de la industria
de cine europeo ha sido escogida como
invitada de honor el país de buñuel y
almodóvar tiene como objetivo aumentar
su producción audiovisual en un 30% de
aquí a 2025 Beatriz Navas es directora
del instituto de cinematografía español
y tenemos por primera vez un plan de
gobierno que se llama España japa
audiovisual de Europa es decir Hay un
plan por primera vez para la industria
creativa atraer rodajes internacionales
este tipo de espacio nos va a permitir
que se conozca una nueva generación de
creadores y creadoras y productores y
productoras me voy a Machu Picchu
perdida estamos ahora en primera línea
también en la animación pero también
estamos destacando en el género
fantástico y terror y ganamos el año
pasado más con una directora mujer el
premio a la mejor película fantástica
europea hacemos dramas Rurales como
asbestas no que además también ha pasado
por éxito Con los césas nosotros tenemos
un lema desde hace un año que es el
momento de nuestro cine
el cine español está este año en la
selección oficial y en secciones
paralelas del festival de cannes
[Música]
la tengo
Gracias Melissa barra y les anunciamos
que el festival de cannes invitó este
año a Harrison Ford para el estreno de
la última entrega de Indiana Jones
también aquí Martin scorsese y su dúo de
actores Robert de Niro y Leonardo
DiCaprio Pero de todo eso y de todas las
superestrellas presentes en cannes les
hablaremos en el próximo Carrusel de las
artes mexi
[Música]